I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi there. Today we're going to talk about body language. Let's do it. It's season six, episode 23, written by Justin Spitzer and directed by Mindy Kaling. Here's a summary. Michael tries to interpret the body language of Jim and Pam's potential client, who he believes is interested in him. That client is Donna, the manager of
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。你好。大家好。今天我们要谈谈肢体语言。开始吧。这是第六季第二十三集，由贾斯汀·斯皮策编剧，明迪·卡灵执导。剧情梗概如下：迈克尔试图解读吉姆和帕姆潜在客户的肢体语言，他认为对方对她有意思。这位客户就是唐娜，他是
Sid and Dexter's. She's come in to buy some printers. Meanwhile, Gabe is recruiting for Saber's Print and All Colors Minority Executive Program. But Dwight's going to get involved. He has opinions. Yeah. Fast fact number one, this episode was directed by our very own Mindy Kaling. This is the first episode of The Office that Mindy has directed, but she had also directed the Subtle Sexuality and the Third Floor Office web series. And those were each three miniature episodes long. She will go on to direct Michael's Last Dundies in season seven. And something I realized. What? I was thinking about it. Season six was a really big season for our cast and crew members to direct episodes. Yes. And also
Sid and Dexter 餐厅的经理。她来买一些打印机。与此同时，加布正在为萨博的“色彩打印全员少数族裔高管计划”招募人选。但德怀特也要插手。他很有意见。是的。趣味事实一，这一集由我们亲爱的明迪·卡灵执导。这是明迪执导的第一集《办公室》，但她此前还执导过网络剧《微妙的性吸引力》和《三楼办公室》。这两部网络剧每部都有三个微型剧集那么长。她后来还将执导第七季的《迈克尔的最后表彰会》。我突然意识到一件事。什么事？我刚才在想。第六季对我们剧组的演员和工作人员来说，是执导剧集非常重要的一季。没错。而且还有
some of our writers' assistants to get episodes to write. Well, you know, next week, Rainn Wilson is going to direct his first episode, The Cover Up. So I needed a stat. I was inspired. Is this like a Dr. Thibodeau moment? A little bit. Okay, let's hear it. Inspired by. Of the 26 episodes in season six, only eight episodes were directed by a non-cast or crew member. And we only had three new directors come on the show. They were Reggie Hudlin, Seth Gordon, and Mark Webb. Everybody else was returning or cast or crew. Only three new for such a big season. I know. Well, I love a good stat. Thank you, Angela. You're welcome. Do you love a good mini deep dive? Do I? My Fast Fag number two is a mini deep
一些编剧助理也得到了编写剧集的机会。嗯，你知道的，下周雷恩·威尔逊将执导他的第一集《掩盖真相》。所以我需要一个统计数据。我被启发了。这就像是蒂博多博士时刻吗？有点像。好吧，说来听听。灵感来自于。在第六季的26集里，只有8集是由非演员或非剧组人员执导的。我们只有三位新导演加入该剧。他们是雷吉·哈德林、赛斯·戈登和马克·韦布。其他所有人都是回归人员、演员或剧组人员。如此庞大的一季竟然只有三位新人。我知道。不过我很喜欢有趣的统计数据。谢谢你，安吉拉。不客气。你喜欢精彩的小型深入探讨吗？我怎么会不喜欢？我的趣味事实二是一个小型深入
dive, but I would like to hear the sting that my son made. It's an oldie but a goodie. Oh, I love it. The deep dive sting. Oh, gee, sting. I know one of our very first. All right, lady, this is a deep dive into the subject of body language. Anthropologist Ray Birdwistel, bird whistel, bird whistel, bird whistel, bird whistel, bird whistel, bird whistel. That looks like bird whistel. Well, Ray pioneered the original study of body language or nonverbal communication, which he called kinesics. Hmm. He determined that the average person actually speaks for only 10 or 11 minutes a day. He does not hang out with us. He's never met us. What? I know. Who are these people? I don't know. But he said that the average sentence only takes about two and a half seconds to say again.
探讨，但我先想听听我儿子做的音效。这是一个老牌但经典的音效。哦，我太喜欢了。深入探讨的音效。哦，天哪，音效。我知道这是我们的早期作品之一。好吧，女士们，这是一次关于肢体语言主题的深入探讨。人类学家雷·伯德惠斯特尔，伯德惠斯特尔，伯德惠斯特尔，伯德惠斯特尔，伯德惠斯特尔，伯德惠斯特尔，伯德惠斯特尔。这看起来就像是伯德惠斯特尔。好吧，雷是肢体语言或非语言沟通原创研究的先驱，他称之为身势学。嗯。他确定普通人实际上每天只说10到11分钟的话。他可不跟我们混在一起。他从没见过我们。什么？我知道。这些人都是谁？我不知道。但他说，平均每个句子只需要大约两秒半的时间就能说完。再说一次，
I don't know who Ray is hanging out with whistleblower. Wait, it's not whistleblower. Word with bird whistel. Oh my God. Ray bird whistel. He also believed that over 65% of our communication is done nonverbally. When it comes to business, which applies to this episode, in analysis of thousands of recorded sales interviews and negotiations during the 1970s and 1980s, researchers found that in business encounters, body language accounted for between 60 to 80% of the impact made around a negotiating table. So like if you have like confident body energy, I'm fascinated. Keep going. Okay. They also found that people form up to 80% of their initial opinions about a person in less than four minutes. Wow, you have four minutes, guys. You have four minutes. Studies also
我不知道雷平时都跟谁在 whistle 混在一起。等等，不是 whistle。是 bird whistel（伯德惠斯特尔）。天哪。雷·伯德惠斯特尔。他还认为，我们65%以上的沟通都是通过非语言方式进行的。说到商业领域，这也适用于这一集，在对20世纪70年代和80年代数千次录制的销售访谈和谈判进行分析后，研究人员发现，在商业交往中，肢体语言在谈判桌上产生的影响力占到60%到80%之间。所以，如果你拥有自信的身体能量……我太着迷了。继续说。好的。他们还发现，人们在不到四分钟的时间内，就能对一个人形成高达80%的最初印象。哇，你们只有四分钟，伙计们。你们只有四分钟。研究还
showed that when people are negotiating over the telephone, the person with the stronger argument usually wins. But this is not true when negotiating face to face because overall, many final decisions were based on what we see rather than what we hear. Get ready for this though. Okay. So you know, a big part of this episode is everyone in the office kind of telling Michael that Donna does not have feelings for him or some people think she might. There's sort of a debate happening between Pam and the rest of the bullpen. But it's only Pam and the rest of the bullpen. Yeah. But I feel like Pam represents people that might think that. Who? I don't know. When I watched it, I kept asking the same questions Pam was asking, like, why is she still here? Yes, as an audience member. But
表明，当人们通过电话进行谈判时，论据更充分的那个人通常会赢。但面对面谈判时情况并非如此，因为总的来说，许多最终决定是基于我们看到的内容，而不是我们听到内容。不过，请做好心理准备。好的。所以你知道的，这一集很大一部分内容是办公室里的每个人都在某种程度上告诉迈克尔，唐娜对他没有感觉，或者有些人认为她可能有。帕姆和其余的职员之间似乎正在发生一场辩论。但只有帕姆和其余的职员。是的。但我觉得帕姆代表了那些可能会这么想的人。谁？我不知道。当我观看的时候，我一直在问帕姆一直在问的那些问题，比如，她为什么还在这里？是的，作为一个观众。但是
within the office, the only voice we hear that there might be interest is Pam's, right? Yeah. Well, from the book, the definitive book of body language by Alan and Barbara Peace from September 2006, most women have the brain organization to out communicate any man on the planet. That's a quote. I'm just saying. You're just quoting. I'm quoting. Magnetic resonance imaging brain scans clearly show why women have a far greater capacity for communicating with and evaluating people than men do. It is because women have between 14 and 16 areas of the brain to evaluate others behavior versus men's four to six areas. That is fascinating. Literally more areas of the brain. This book says this explains how a woman can attend a dinner party and rapidly
在办公室内部，我们听到的唯一认为可能有兴趣的声音就是帕姆的，对吧？是的。嗯，根据艾伦和芭芭拉·皮斯于2006年9月出版的书籍《肢体语言权威指南》，大多数女性的大脑组织结构使她们的沟通能力超越星球上的任何男性。这是一句引言。我只是说说而已。你只是在引用。我在引用。磁共振成像大脑扫描清楚地显示了为什么女性在与人沟通和评估他人方面的能力远远超过男性。这是因为女性大脑中有14到16个区域用于评估他人的行为，而男性只有4到6个区域。太迷人了。字面意义上拥有更多的大脑区域。这本书说，这解释了为什么一个女性可以参加晚宴，并迅速
work out the state of the relationships of the other couples at the party who's had an argument, who likes who, who doesn't like who, and so on. And it explains why from a woman standpoint, men don't seem to talk much. And from a men's standpoint, women seem to never shut up. That's a quote from the book. It is so funny to me because there will be some parent thing that we attend. We go to so many, you know, for school and stuff, soccer and we'll leave. And I always call it the car ride home conversation. Like, I can't wait for the car ride home conversation. Yes, that's where we get to download about all the stuff we saw at the event. And I get in the car and I'm like, Josh, did you catch that? And he's like, what are you talking about? And I'm like,
弄清楚晚宴上其他夫妇的关系状态——谁和谁吵过架，谁喜欢谁，谁不喜欢谁，诸如此类。这也解释了为什么从女性的角度来看，男性似乎不太爱说话。而从男性的角度来看，女性似乎永远也说个不停。这是书中的原话。这对我来说太搞笑了，因为总会有一些我们参加的家长活动。你知道的，我们为了学校之类的事情去参加了那么多活动，比如足球赛，然后我们要离开了。我总是把它叫做“回家的车程谈话”。就像，我迫不及待地想要进行回家的车程谈话。是的，那是我们能够倾诉我们在活动中看到的所有事情的时候。我上车后就会说：“乔什，你注意到了吗？”而他却说：“你在说什么？”然后我就……
ah, yeah, same. Yeah, car ride home. Lee likes the car ride home because I tell him all the stuff I saw. I have even more information about this. I couldn't stop. Research by psychologists at Harvard University showed how women are far more alert to body language than men. They showed men and women short films with the sound turned off of a man and a woman communicating and the participants had to decode what was happening just by reading the expressions on the screen. The research showed that women were able to read the situation correctly 87% of the time, but men could only do it 42% of the time. Sorry guys, but they did say that men in nurturing occupations such as stay at home dads, artistic types, acting, nursing, they did nearly as well as the women did. Gay men also scored very
啊，是的，一样。是的，回家的车程。李喜欢回家的车程，因为我会把看到的所有事情都告诉他。关于这个，我还有更多信息。我根本停不下来。哈佛大学心理学家的研究表明，女性对肢体语言的敏感度远高于男性。他们向男女两性展示了关闭声音的短片，内容是一男一女在交流，参与者必须仅通过阅读屏幕上的表情来解码发生了什么。研究表明，女性有87%的时间能够正确解读情况，而男性只有42%的概率。对不起啦各位，但他们确实说过，从事培育性职业的男性，比如全职奶爸、艺术类工作者、表演、护理，他们的表现几乎和女性一样好。同性恋男性的得分也非常
well and new mothers scored highest. And they believed that that was because they were spending all day reading the nonverbal body language cues of their infants. And so they were very finely attuned to these signs. Yeah. I think this is proof why Pam, a new mother and a woman is reading the body language correctly and no one else is. Do you think Justin Spitzer had that in mind? I doubt it, but it makes sense. It is backed up by scientific research. I loved all of that. Did you like that? I could hear more. Okay. I feel like I've been talking a long time. Fastback number three, Angela is all yours because Angela got in touch with Hide. Yes, we have been trading messages. We finally connected and I am so excited. Well,
高，而新手妈妈的得分最高。他们认为这是因为新手妈妈整天都在解读婴儿的非语言肢体语言线索。因此她们对这些迹象非常敏感。是的。我认为这证明了为什么帕姆这个新手妈妈兼女性能够正确解读肢体语言，而其他人却不能。你觉得贾斯汀·斯皮策在写的时候想到了这一点吗？我怀疑他没有，但这确实说得通。它有科学研究的支持。我太喜欢所有这些了。你喜欢吗？我还能听更多。好的。我觉得我已经说了好久了。趣味事实三，安吉拉，全归你了，因为安吉拉跟Hide取得联系了。是的，我们一直在互发信息。我们终于联系上了，我太兴奋了。嗯，
you know, he had that great talking head in happy hour and then he comes back again in this episode. I know. So Hide Toshi Amora plays Hide in the warehouse and I asked him about his time on the show. He had the most wonderful answers. I'm going to sprinkle them throughout the episode, but I thought I would start with two of the questions I asked him in Fastback three. Great. My first question to Hide was our standard question, Jenna. How did you come to be on the office? Here's what he said. Way before doing that big talking head, you know, in happy hour, he did background work as an extra for the show. At that time, he said he had no idea what the show was about, but his manager called him and asked if he wanted to do some work as an extra.
你知道的，他在《欢乐时光》里有一段精彩的面对镜头独白，然后在这集里他又回来了。我知道。扮演仓库里的Hide的其实是秀俊阿村，我向他询问了他在该剧中的经历。他给出了最精彩的回答。我将把这些回答穿插在整集中，不过我想先从我在趣味事实三中向他提出的两个问题开始。太棒了。我向Hide提出的第一个问题是我们的标准问题，珍娜。你是怎么加入《办公室》的？他是这么说的。早在进行那段精彩的面对镜头独白之前，你知道的，就是在《欢乐时光》里，他曾为该剧担任背景演员或临时演员。当时，他说他根本不知道这部剧是关于什么的，但他的经纪人打电话问他愿不愿意做一些临时演员的工作。
So he said, sure, and went along with it. After some time of being a background player, his manager called him and said, they want you to audition for an unknown bigger role in the show, like a featured role. He said the role wasn't actually defined at the time. So he had no idea what they wanted or what to expect. Hmm. He went to the audition and he said there was a wide variety of different people from all backgrounds. He said that when it was time for his audition, he thought he completely botched it. Oh, no. Yeah. He said he was embarrassed and he went to his car and he got in his car and as he was about to turn it on, he decided, no, I can't let it in like this. What? Yeah. He got out of his car and immediately asked for a re-audition on the spot.
所以他说，当然可以，然后就去了。在当了一段时间的背景演员后，他的经纪人打电话告诉他：“他们想让你去为剧中一个未知的重要角色试镜，就像一个有台词的角色。”他说当时这个角色其实并没有明确定义。所以他完全不知道他们想要什么，也不知道该期待什么。嗯。他去参加了试镜，他说现场有来自各种背景的形形色色的人。他说，当轮到他试镜时，他觉得自己彻底搞砸了。哦，不。是的。他说他感到很尴尬，于是走到车里，上了车。正当他要发动汽车时，他决定，不，我不能就这样放弃。什么？是的。他下了车，立刻要求当场重新试镜。
I love this. Then he said they were like, sure. And he auditioned again and he said, I bombed again. Oh, no. He said he felt defeated and he went back home and when he was at his lowest and about to go to bed, he got a call from his manager saying, you got the job. Oh my gosh. This is every actor's story, I have to say. How many times has this happened to you? So many of you are like, oh, that was horrible. And then they're like, oh, guess what? You got it. Or you're like, I nailed it. Yeah. And they're like, we've gone another way. Yes. So many times. Well, I remember when they did this audition process, they wanted to fill out the warehouse and they knew now that the warehouse was going to be more than just background, that they were going to want to throw lines to
我太喜欢这个了。然后他说对方回答说：“当然可以。”于是他又试了一次，接着他说：“我又演砸了。”哦，不。他说他感到很受挫，然后回到了家。就在他情绪最低落、准备上床睡觉的时候，他接到了经纪人的电话，对方说：“你被录用了。”天哪。我得说，这简直是每个演员的故事。这种事在你身上发生过多少次？你们有多少人会觉得：“哦，太糟糕了。”然后他们就会说：“哦，你猜怎么着？你被录用了。”或者你觉得自己表现完美。是的。而他们却说：“我们已经决定用其他人了。”是的，太多次了。嗯，我记得当他们进行这个试镜过程时，他们想要填满仓库，而且他们现在知道了仓库不只是作为背景，他们想要给
people. So they were trying to fill the warehouse with people who could do speaking roles as well. So I totally remember this. Well, I also asked he day if he had any favorite memories from his time on the set. And this is what he shared. And Jenna, it's so sweet. What? Here's what he said. And I quote, I finally remember a moment when I had to do ad-libbing on the spot with Jenna for one of the scenes. And even though my English is not very good, I had a fun time trying my best to keep the conversation going and entertaining. At that moment, I remembered why I love acting so much. Oh, that means so much to me. I know. Well, I remember that it was in season nine and he was great. I just loved connecting with him. I'm going to share a few more of his
人们安排台词。所以他们试图在仓库里填满那些也能扮演有台词角色的演员。所以我完全记得这个。嗯，我还问了Hide他在片场有没有什么最喜欢的记忆。这就是他分享的内容。而且珍娜，太暖心了。什么？他是这么说的。我引述一下：“我清晰地记得有一次，我不得不和珍娜在其中一个场景中进行现场即兴发挥。尽管我的英语不是很好，但我还是度过了一段有趣的时光，尽最大努力让对话继续下去并充满娱乐性。在那一刻，我想起了为什么我如此热爱表演。”哦，这对我有很深的意义。我知道。嗯，我记得那是在第九季，他演得很棒。我太喜欢与他交流了。我会在
stories along the way. But lady, before we get into the episode, would you like to know what we were doing the week we filmed this episode in March of 2010? Is this a bit of Angela's digital clutter? It sure is. Angela's digital clutter. Thank you. Apparently, Jenna, I was very into making banana bread during this time. And I was bragging to you in an email about my banana bread. And I had brought some to set. And you had tried it and you really liked it. And you emailed me asking me for my banana bread recipe. To which I replied, four to five mashed bananas, use ripe ones. Why did I like, like, you know what? A novice banana bread baker wouldn't know. Okay. Then I said two cups all purpose flour, one cup sugar or less if you can't see your toes. I'm making jokes
接下来的时间里分享他的更多故事。不过女士们，在我们进入正剧之前，你们想知道我们在2010年3月拍摄这一周都在做什么吗？这是安吉拉的数码杂物吗？当然是。安吉拉的数码杂物。谢谢。显然，珍娜，那时候我非常热衷于做香蕉面包。我还在一封邮件里向你吹嘘我的香蕉面包。我还带了一些到片场。你尝过之后真的很喜欢。你给我发邮件索要我的香蕉面包配方。对此我的回复是：四到五根捣碎的香蕉，要用熟透的。我为什么会像……你知道吗？一个新手香蕉面包烘焙师可能不知道。好吧。然后我说两杯通用面粉，一杯糖——如果你看不到自己的脚趾，就少放点。我在开玩笑呢。
here. I'm making jokes in my recipe. Comedy recipe. I know. Two large eggs, half a cup shortening our vegetable oil, one teaspoon baking powder, half a teaspoon salt, one teaspoon vanilla. Enjoy. No nuts, no raisins in that. Nope. Just pure banana bread. Kept it simple. I hope you're going to post that full recipe in Office Ladies Pod Stories on Instagram. I will post it exactly as I emailed it to you. Very good. Are you still making that banana bread? I am, except now I do one other thing with it. What? I put a little powdered sugar on top. Oh. At the end, you know, after you've let it cool, put a little powdered sugar on top. Are you allowed to do that if you can see your toes only? I guess not. And sometimes I put many chocolate chips in it. Oh, I know. It really
我在我的食谱里开玩笑。喜剧食谱。我知道。两个大鸡蛋，半杯起酥油或植物油，一茶匙泡打粉，半茶匙盐，一茶匙香草精。请享用。里面没有坚果，也没有葡萄干。没错。只有纯粹的香蕉面包。保持简单。我希望你会把这个完整的食谱发布到Instagram的“办公室女士播客故事”里。我会完全按照我发邮件给你的那样发布。非常好。你还在做那个香蕉面包吗？在做，只不过现在我对它做了另一个改动。什么？我会在上面撒一点糖粉。哦。在最后，你知道的，等它冷却之后，在上面撒一点糖粉。只有当你能看到自己的脚趾时，才允许这样做吗？我想不能。有时我会在里面放一些迷你巧克力豆。哦，我知道。它真的
has graduated to more of a treat. I know. Well, let's take a break. And when we get back, I have some very interesting inter-office memos between our show and NBC's Standards and Practices. Oh, I can't wait. All right. Well, this episode starts with a very chipper, Michael. He is going to greet Aaron in Spanish and insist that she answers the phone in Spanish. He's very excited about speaking Spanish. Well, he has the talking head where he says that he believes everyone should learn Spanish. He has a lot of thoughts about it. And then he says, oh, also, I'm going on vacation to Cancun next week. Who is he going on vacation with? I know. By himself? To Cancun. I thought it was odd. I know. Well, he holds up a little brochure. That was designed by our graphic designer,
已经升级为更像是一种犒赏了。我知道。好吧，我们休息一下。等我们回来后，我有一些关于我们剧集和NBC审查标准部门之间非常有趣的办公室内部备忘录。哦，我已经迫不及待了。好的。嗯，这一集开始时，迈克尔精神焕发。他用西班牙语向艾伦打招呼，并坚持让她用西班牙语接电话。他对说西班牙语感到非常兴奋。嗯，他在面对镜头独白时说，他认为每个人都应该学西班牙语。他对此有很多想法。然后他说：“哦，对了，我下周要去坎昆度假。”他是和谁一起去度假的？我知道。他自己一个人？去坎昆。我觉得这很奇怪。我知道。嗯，他举起了一份小册子。那是我们的平面设计师
Henry Sane. You know, he was very busy this week. I'm going to point it out throughout the episode. He made a lot of stuff starting with fakie Cancun brochure. Ding, ding, ding. Number one, Henry Sane Tracker. Well, Michael is now going to go up to Jim and speak Spanish. And guess what? Jim is really good, which is curious because we had a fan catch from Elsa N in Utah and many others who said in night out season four, episode 15, Jim asks Oscar to translate when the cleaning crew comes to clean the office and they need to be let out of the parking lot. However, in body language, Jim says multiple sentences in Spanish, which makes you think he can speak it pretty well. Huh. Someone was not following the show Bible. I guess not. Also, though,
亨利·塞恩设计的。你知道的，他这周非常忙。我会在整集中不断指出这一点。他制作了许多东西，从那个假的坎昆宣传册开始。叮，叮，叮。第一号，亨利·塞恩追踪器。嗯，迈克尔现在走向吉姆并说起西班牙语。你猜怎么着？吉姆说得非常好，这就很奇怪了，因为我们收到了来自犹他州的Elsa N以及许多其他人的粉丝爆料，他们说在第四季第十五集《告别单身夜》中，吉姆在清洁工来打扫办公室且需要被放停车场时，让奥斯卡进行翻译。然而在《肢体语言》这一集中，吉姆用西班牙语说了好几个句子，这让人觉得他西班牙语说得相当不错。哼。有人没有遵循剧集圣经。看来是的。不过与此同时，
a fan question from honey. Oh, in Puerto Rico, I have a Spanish catch that bothers me every time I watch this episode. In the cold open, Jim is showing off his Spanish to Michael, but then he says, Yo soy fantástico. In this specific context in which Jim is asking Michael how he's doing, that phrase is grammatically incorrect. You can use I am in English to describe a state of being, but not in Spanish by saying, Yo soy fantástico. You're showing off that you are a fantastic person. The correct phrasing is Yo estoy fantástico, which means that you feel great. Yes. You know what? When he said that, something went off in my brain as error. It's like some Spanish lesson I learned long ago in a file that honey just unopened. Thank you, honey.
还有一个来自波多黎各的粉丝蜜蜂（Honey）的问题。我有关于西班牙语的槽点，每次看这一集我都觉得难受。在开场白中，吉姆在迈克尔面前炫耀他的西班牙语，但他却说：“Yo soy fantástico。”在这个特定的语境下，吉姆是在问迈克尔过得怎么样，这个短语在语法上是不正确的。你可以在英语中使用“I am”来描述一种状态，但在西班牙语中不能说“Yo soy fantástico”。你在炫耀自己是一个绝妙的人。正确的说法是“Yo estoy fantástico”，意思是感觉棒极了。是的。你知道吗？当他说那句话时，我大脑里的某个警报器响了。就像我很久以前在某个文件夹里学到的西班牙语课，被蜜蜂刚才给重新打开了。谢谢你，蜜蜂。
Yes. Well, I looked in the script and none of that was in the script. In fact, Dwight's greeting was completely different as well. I think they built this on the day and that's how the mistake happened. I concur with your theory. Well, now Oscar is helping Michael. Oscar shares with us that Michael is really struggling with the gender part of Spanish. And so he told Michael to use the international symbol for gender on all the different items in his office so he could learn how to say them properly in Spanish. Yes. He has covered his office with post-it notes that contain what Michael believes to be the international sign for female and male. But they are penises and boobs. Yeah. We got a fan question from Kim W. and Washington,
是的。嗯，我看过剧本，剧本里根本没有这些。事实上，德怀特的问候方式也完全不同。我认为他们是在拍摄当天现场即兴创作的，错误就是这样发生的。我同意你的理论。嗯，现在奥斯卡正在帮助迈克尔。奥斯卡跟我们分享说，迈克尔在西班牙语的性别部分遇到了很大困难。所以他告诉迈克尔在办公室的各种物品上贴上国际通用的性别符号，这样他就能学会如何在西班牙语中正确地称呼它们。是的。他的办公室贴满了便利贴，上面画着迈克尔认为是女性和男性的国际符号。但它们其实是阴茎和乳房。是的。我们收到了来自伊利诺伊州华盛顿镇的Kim W的粉丝提问：
Illinois. Did all of the post-its have genitals on them? And if so, who was in charge of drawing those? Oh my gosh. What a great question. It's like, honey, would you do at work today? Well, I had a stack of 100 post-it notes that I had to draw boobs on. Yeah. That's pretty much it. So those drawings were courtesy of our graphic designer, Henry Sain. Oh, Henry. According to Randy, Henry actually had to draw quote varying degrees of explicitness. Oh my gosh. They had to pick. They had samples of Henry's drawings. Yes. A variety of samples were presented to Greg and Paul, and they had to pick which ones would go in the episode. I cannot believe Henry's day that day. So Randy also shared that the process for getting this
所有的便利贴上都有生殖器吗？如果是的话，是谁负责画这些的？天哪。多棒的问题啊。就像是，蜜蜂，你今天在工作做什麽？嗯，我有一叠100张的便利贴，我必须在上面画乳房。是的。差不多就是这样。所以这些画作是由我们的平面设计师亨利·塞恩倾情提供的。哦，亨利。据兰迪透露，亨利实际上不得不画出“不同明晰程度的”画作。天哪。他们不得不挑选。他们有亨利画作的样本。是的。各种各样的样本被呈交给格雷格和保罗，他们必须挑选哪些应该放进剧集里。我简直不敢相信亨利那天的遭遇。所以兰迪还分享说，让这个
scene cleared with standards and practices was insane. After the table read, Randy sent the script over to NBC, and they responded by saying, you can do the post-it notes, but they have to be blurred. Okay. Okay. So after we filmed it and they did a cut of the cold open, Greg and Paul sent over a version to standards and practices, but nothing was blurred. Well, that didn't go over well. They just sent over the full drawing. That's right. Yeah. Randy got a note back that said, quote, please blur all of the post-its around Michael's office that have visible breasts and penises drawn on them, including the one on Angela's forehead. That was literally a quote in the memo. Greg and Paul were not having it. They pushed back. They argued that it was much
场景通过审查标准部门（Standards and Practices）审核的过程简直疯狂。剧本围读后，兰迪把剧本发给了NBC，他们的回应是：你可以用便利贴，但必须进行模糊处理。好吧。好吧。所以在我们拍摄完毕并剪辑出开场白后，格雷格和保罗向审查部门发送了一个版本，但没有任何模糊处理。嗯，这可没那么容易过关。他们直接发送了完整的画作。没错。是的。兰迪收到了回复便条，上面写着：“请将迈克尔办公室周围所有带有清晰可见乳房和阴茎画作的便利贴进行模糊处理，包括贴在安吉拉额头上的那张。”这简直是备忘录里的原话。格雷格和保罗可不买账。他们进行了反击。他们争辩说，看到迈克尔幼稚的艺术作品要
funnier to see Michael's crude artwork. They said that they were going for a joke about Michael's childlike innocence using what he thinks are the symbols of man and woman, and they believe that the audience would understand the context and not be offended by these drawings. They went on to say, oh my gosh, the painting of the Sistine Chapel in the Vatican contains more detailed nudity than these post-it notes. They're invoking the Sistine Chapel? Yes. And they had Randy attach a photo of the Sistine Chapel to their argument. What if this becomes a new thing where if you have an argument about whatever you invoke the Sistine Chapel? That's right. This was their response. Quote, we agree that the drawings are silly. Having said that, we have had this exact
搞笑得多。他们表示，他们追求的是一个关于迈克尔纯真童心的笑话，他用的是他自认为的男女符号，他们相信观众会理解这种语境，不会被这些画作冒犯。他们接着说，天哪，梵蒂冈西斯廷礼拜堂的壁画包含的裸露细节比这些便利贴还要多。他们搬出了西斯廷礼拜堂？是的。他们还让兰迪在他们的论点中附上了一张西斯廷礼拜堂的照片。如果这成了一种新趋势，不管遇到什么争论都要搬出西斯廷礼拜堂怎么办？没错。这是他们的回复。原话：“我们同意这些画作很蠢。话虽如此，我们在其他节目中也处理过完全相同的问题，法务部门不愿意冒这个险并允许这样做。请将这些图像进行模糊处理。附言：我们对你们引用的西斯廷礼拜堂不屑一顾。”
issue to address on other shows and legal is not willing to take the risk and allow this. Please blur the images. P.S. We don't give a crap about your Sistine Chapel reference. Greg and Paul were not convinced. Come on. They took it themselves to the NBC legal department and the NBC legal department said, blur it. That still wasn't the end. No. They sent a sample of the cold open finally with the images blurred and they wrote back more blurry. Come on. Yeah. Yeah. Finally, their second attempt at blurring the post-its was approved and that is what you see in the episode. That is hilarious to me that Greg and Paul became so determined. Yeah. Exactly. All right. So this episode has such a fun Jim Pam storyline. I really enjoyed it.
格雷格和保罗并没有被说服。拜托。他们亲自带着开场白的样本找到了NBC法务部门，NBC法务部门说：模糊处理。但这还不是结束。不。他们最终发送了一份对图像进行了模糊处理的开场白样本，结果对方回复：再模糊一点。拜托。对啊。对啊。最终，他们第二次尝试对便利贴进行模糊处理的方案获得了批准，这就是你在剧集里看到的画面。这对我来说太搞笑了，格雷格和保罗竟然如此执着。没错。就是这样。好吧。所以这一集有一个非常有趣的吉姆和帕姆的故事线。我真的很喜欢。
Pam's enthusiasm for their joint sales pitch is so stinking cute and Jim does not know what to do with her. She's just turned into this whole other person with comedy bits and she's got shtick and the whole time they're talking, I just wanted more. I wanted to see more of this dynamic. I give he takes. I know. Yeah. By the way, during that double talking head, when you go, hey, at the end, I am telling you that final look to camera was just John. I think so too. Because I think you surprised him and he was like, oh gosh. Well, we had a fan question from Kyle T. in Houston, Texas. Jenna, who did you model Pam's comedy after in this episode? Oh, please do tell. Well, in the script, there was a note that said I should do a quote,
帕姆对他们共同销售演示的热情简直可爱透顶，而吉姆却不知道该拿她怎么办。她整个人仿佛变成了另一个人，充满了喜剧桥段和滑稽表演，他们谈话的全程我都希望看到更多。我只想要看到更多这种互动。一应一和。我知道。是的。顺便说一句，在那段双人面对镜头独白中，当你在最后说“嘿”的时候，我跟你讲，最后那个看向摄像头的眼神完全就是约翰本人的反应。我也这么觉得。因为我觉得你把他给惊艳到了，他当时的表情就像是，哦天哪。嗯，我们收到了来自德克萨斯州休斯顿的Kyle T的粉丝提问：珍娜，你在这集里是以谁为原型来塑造帕姆的喜剧风格的？哦，请务必告诉我们。
vaudeville take on those lines. And you did. I did it. We also got a fan question from Fiona L. in Melbourne, Australia. Pam has been very suity and hair up lately. She seems to be hitting it quite hard. Does this design indicate she's trying to fake it until she makes it with sales? What was the intention here? Fiona, I'd like to invite you to Jenna's digital clutter. Oh, Jenna's digital clutter from her digital pockets. All right. Thank you. I love it. I love it. Thank you, Audrey. Audrey did that sting, Sam's girlfriend. Yes, she did. And it is so fun. Digital pockets. Well, here's what I've got in my digital pockets, folks. Pam's hair was up last week too. And when I saw it for
嗯，剧本里有一条备注，上面说我应该对这些台词做一个“杂耍风格的演绎”。而你确实这么做了。我照做了。我们还收到了来自澳大利亚墨尔本的Fiona L的粉丝提问：帕姆最近总是穿西装，头发也盘起来了。她似乎对此非常投入。这种造型是否表明她想在销售上“假装成功直到真正成功”？这里的意图是什么？菲奥娜，我想邀请你来到珍娜的数码杂物。哦，来自她数码口袋的珍娜的数码杂物。好的。谢谢你。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。谢谢你，奥黛丽。奥黛丽制作了那个音效，那是萨姆的女友。是的，她做了。太有趣了。数码口袋。
the second time this week, I remembered that Kim Ferry and I had a long discussion about what Pam's hair would be like after having CC. That's what I thought. Yes. And my digital clutter confirmed it. I found an email from Kim titled, Pam mom hair. And we were trying to decide if Pam would cut her hair or put her hair up after having the baby. But either way, we had this whole backstory that Pam had to keep her hair shorter or up because it was like getting in the way of things. Also, who has the time? Yeah. I mean, when you have a newborn, you just throw your hair up in something. Well, guess what Kim had sent me? What? She had sent me a photo of our Pam haircut test. She put a wig on me. Oh, please tell me I can put that in stories. You can. Of Pam having
她给我发了一张我们的帕姆发型测试照片。她给我戴了一顶假发。哦，请告诉我我可以把它发到快拍里。你可以。那是帕姆留着短发的照片。有趣的是，它看起来有点像我现在的发型。哦，所以是的。最终，我们决定还是把帕姆的头发盘起来。我太喜欢这个细节了。嗯，现在吉姆和帕姆正准备接待的客户要进来了，你猜是谁？就是唐娜·牛顿，Sid and Dexter餐厅的经理。迈克尔说：“有人点妓女了吗？”这就是他的开场白。这就是他的恭维。是的。这就是他的开场白。嗯，有一个非常有趣的克里德支线。在删减片段里。当唐娜到达时，克里德躲了起来，原因如下。
a short haircut. Interestingly enough, it looks quite a bit like my haircut now. Oh, so yeah. Ultimately, we decided to just pin up Pam's hair. I love that detail. Well, now the client that Jim and Pam are planning to woo is going to come on in and guess who it is? It's Donna Newton, the manager of Sid and Dexter's. Did somebody order a hooker, Michael says? That is what he leads with. That's his compliment. Yeah. That's what he leads with. Well, there was a really fun Creed runner. It's in deleted scenes. When Donna arrives, Creed hides and here's why. I guess you remember everybody else from when we visited you at your restaurant. I bet you memorized what everybody drinks. Not really. No. No. Yeah, dined and dashed. Usually they don't follow you to your
好的，这就是我放在数码口袋里的东西，各位。帕姆上周就把头发盘起来了。当这周第二次看到时，我记起了金·费瑞和我曾深入探讨过帕姆生完西西后发型会是什么样。我也这么觉得。是的，而我的数码杂物证实了这一点。我找到了一封金发来的邮件，标题是“帕姆妈妈发型”。我们当时在试图决定帕姆在生完孩子后是该剪短发还是把头发盘起来。但无论如何，我们都有这样一个完整的背景设定：帕姆必须把头发剪短或盘起来，因为头发总是在做事时碍事。另外，谁有那个闲工夫呢？是的。我的意思是，当你有了新生儿，你只会随便把头发往上一扎。嗯，你猜金给我发了什么？什么？
place of work. Happens sometimes. Part of the game. How often is he dining and dashing? I can't imagine he's ever paid for a meal. I agree. I actually agree. So if you watch the episode in that scene in the background, if you don't see Creed, it's because he's hiding. Oh, interesting. Michael's going to have a talking head and he's going to talk about how he met Donna a few weeks ago and now they're in the midst of this passionate love affair. Just kidding. She's just coming to buy printers. They had a whole bunch of candy bag alts for Steve as Michael in this moment. Oh, yeah. I just am picking one to read. But you guys, whenever I look at these candy bags, I am reminded about how many they would hand us. Like three pages. Yeah. Okay. Here's one that I thought
我想你还记得我们在你餐厅拜访你时的所有人。我敢打赌你记住了每个人喝什么。其实并没有。没有。对，吃霸王餐。通常他们不会追到你的工作场所。偶尔会发生。游戏的一部分。他到底多久吃一次霸王餐？我无法想象他付过饭钱。我完全同意。我真的同意。所以如果你在那个场景的背景中观看这一集，如果你没看到克里德，那是因为他在躲藏。哦，有意思。迈克尔将有一段面对镜头独白，他要谈论几周前他是如何遇到唐娜的，现在他们正处于一段充满激情的恋爱关系中。开玩笑的。她只是来买打印机的。在这个时刻，为作为迈克尔的史蒂夫准备了整整一大包替代台词。哦，是的。我只是挑了一句来读。
was funny. Michael alternate talking head. Is Donna attractive? Yes. Am I attractive? I've been called that. Whatever. Yes. Is Donna a manager? Yes. Am I a manager? I pretty much invented the term. Yes. Have I finally met my equal? I'm not thinking about that. I have printers to sell. Oh, I really like that. I loved it. I really like that. Well, now Michael is going to introduce Pam and Jim as the Wonder Twins. Yeah. Sort of implying that they're twins. Yes. And Donna is like, Oh, yeah. I see the resemblance. She says you look exactly alike. Pam Corrects her says, no, no, no, we are married. But Donna is certain that they have some ancestral relation going way back. And then there's a little bit of Angela snark. Yeah. Angela says you should see their baby.
但是各位，每当我看到这些糖果袋时，我就会想起他们会塞给我们多少台词。就像三页纸。是的。好吧，这里有一句我觉得挺好笑的。迈克尔替代独白。唐娜有吸引力吗？是的。我有吸引力吗？有人这么叫过我。随便吧。是的。唐娜是经理吗？是的。我是经理吗？我几乎发明了这个词。是的。我终于遇到势均力敌的人了吗？我没想这个。我有打印机要卖。哦，我真的很喜欢这个。我太喜欢了。我真的很喜欢。嗯，现在迈克尔要介绍帕姆和吉姆为“神奇双胞胎”。是的。有点暗示他们是双胞胎的意思。是的。而唐娜则说：“哦，是的。我看得出长得很像。”她
And I went to the script because the script note for this unspoken exchange between Pam and Angela that follows is amazing. It says this, Angela shakes her head slightly like something's not right with it. Angle on Pam. What the ****? That's what the script said. I also love that Angela like clearly has been thinking about this because her first responses, I knew it. Yeah. Well, Jim is now presenting to Donna in the conference room, their sales pitch for my folks that love to see what happens in the conference room. Who is moving the tables? Who is moving the chairs? Why are all the chairs stacked in the far left corner? Who did that? There's a stack of chairs. There's a stack of chairs. Well, at three minutes and 41 seconds,
说你们长得一模一样。帕姆纠正她说：“不，不，不，我们是夫妻。”但唐娜确信他们有什么可以追溯到很久以前的祖先血缘关系。接着安吉拉进行了一番冷嘲热讽。是的。安吉拉说：“你们应该看看他们的孩子。”我特意去查了剧本，因为随后帕姆和安吉拉之间这段无声交流的剧本备注太棒了。上面是这样写的：安吉拉微微摇了摇头，好像有什么地方不对劲。镜头转向帕姆。搞什么鬼？剧本里就是这么写的。我还喜欢安吉拉显然一直在想这件事，因为她的第一反应是：我早就知道了。嗯，吉姆现在正在会议室里向唐娜展示他们针对那些喜欢看会议室里发生什么的粉丝们的销售方案。谁在搬桌子？谁在搬椅子？为什么所有的椅子都堆在左远角？谁干的？那里有一堆椅子。
that graphic that Jim is showing to Donna that was designed by Henry saying that's three now on our count. Michael's going to walk in and he has a very time sensitive question. He needs to know if Donna would like this Victoria's Secret catalog because the sale ends soon. She's like, yeah, I love it. Thank you. Can I say something about Victoria's Secret? I don't mean to be controversial. I was going to say, here we go. I don't think they make the best bras. I just, like as a teenager, I don't know. I feel like I got all the promotional stuff and to get the best bra, that's where you go. They're very expensive. I don't think they're great. I mean, I've found just much better bras since. I think you can, I don't know,
那里有一堆椅子。嗯，在3分41秒的时候，吉姆向唐娜展示的那个图形是亨利·塞恩设计的，这是我们数出来的第三个。迈克尔走进来，他有一个非常争分夺秒的问题。他需要知道唐娜是否想要这本维多利亚的秘密目录，因为促销快结束了。她回答说：“哦，是的，我太喜欢了。谢谢。”我能说一下关于维多利亚的秘密的事吗？我不是故意挑起争议的。我刚想说，来了来了。我觉得他们做的内衣并不是最好的。我只是觉得，作为一个青少年，我不知道。我觉得我收到了所有宣传资料，而要想买到最好的内衣，那里才是该去的地方。它们非常贵。我觉得它们并不好。我的意思是，从那以后我找到了好得多的内衣。我想你可以，我不知道，
you can skip it in your bra buying journey. Since you're bringing up Victoria's Secrets and the bras. Because I'm bringing up what? Victoria's Secrets. She only has one secret, lady. She doesn't have lots of secrets. No, I think just one. I don't know what it is, but it's Victoria's Secret. Oh, she just has the one secret. I am turning into my mom because my mom pluralizes things that aren't plural, but then she makes things singular that aren't singular. Yeah, so I'm my mom. Okay, so it's not Victoria's many secrets. It's her one secret. And her secret is that her bras are sh**ty. I think that's her secret. I am wearing a no wire bra right now that folks recommended to me. It's got a big band.
在你的内衣购买之旅中你可以跳过它。既然你提到了维多利亚的秘密和内衣。因为我提到了什么？维多利亚的秘密。她只有一个秘密，女士。她没有很多秘密。不，我觉得只有一个。我不知道那是什么，但那就是维多利亚的秘密。哦，她只有一个秘密。我正在变成我妈，因为我妈总是把不复数的东西复数化，然后又把不单数的东西单数化。是的，所以我就是我妈。好吧，所以这不是维多利亚的许多秘密。这是她的一个秘密。而她的秘密就是她的内衣太烂了。我想这就是她的秘密。我身上正穿着一件无钢圈内衣，是大家推荐给我的。它有一个很宽的侧比。
It looks really good. Yeah, it's got a big supportive. It's got a big band. So like the band is substantial and it's from Jockey. This is what I'm saying. I'll send you a link. All right, let's go to the kitchen. Where Gabe is telling Darryl about Saber's print in all colors minority executive training program. For those of you that love a good giant cheeseball container sighting, go to four minutes, 18 seconds. It's very featured behind Dwight during the scene. Well, quickly after that at four minutes and 26 seconds, the print in all colors brochure again, Henry Sane. That's number four. Number four. I'm kind of loving this job. Like if you're a graphic designer, you went to school for graphic design. Is this the best job
看起来真的很不错。是的，它有一个很大的承托力。它有一个很宽的侧比，所以侧比很大而且很厚实，是Jockey的。这就是我想说的。我给你们发个链接。好了，我们去厨房吧。加布正在那里跟达里尔谈论萨博的“色彩打印全员少数族裔高管培训计划”。对于那些喜欢寻找巨大的乳酪球容器出镜的粉丝，请看4分18秒。在这个场景中，它在德怀特身后非常显眼。嗯，在那之后不久的4分钟26秒，色彩打印全员宣传册又出现了，还是亨利·塞恩。那是第四个。第四个。我有点喜欢这份工作了。就像如果你是一个平面设计师，你学的是平面设计专业。这难道不是史上最好的工作吗？
ever? Like designing for a comedy television show. You get to create all kinds of stuff. Yeah, it seems sort of exciting. I'm kind of digging his job. Listen, something we have to talk about though is Dwight. Dwight doesn't understand why Darryl suddenly gets this opportunity and he doesn't. He points out a number of ways that he himself is a minority. He wears glasses, he's a cholera survivor, and he's a genius and a non organic family farmer. Genius. Really Dwight. Interesting. But Dwight's big takeaway from this meeting with Gabe and Darryl is that he does not want a competent hard worker like Darryl to get this job. He wants somebody who he can manipulate. That means Kelly. Yeah. Dwight thinks with this program Darryl might get Michael's
就像为喜剧电视剧做设计一样。你可以创作各种各样的东西。是的，这听起来有点令人兴奋。我挺喜欢他的工作。听着，有一件事我们不得不谈，那就是德怀特。德怀特不明白为什么达里尔突然得到了这个机会而他却没有。他列举了自己属于少数族裔的种种方式。他戴眼镜，他是霍乱幸存者，他是一个天才，还是一个非有机家庭农场主。天才。真的是这样吗，德怀特？有意思。但德怀特从与加布和达里尔这次会面中得出的最大结论是，他不希望像达里尔这样能干又努力的工作狂得到这份工作。他想要一个他可以操纵的人。这意味着凯利。是的。德怀特认为通过这个计划，达里尔可能会得到迈克尔的
position or higher and that's what Dwight has wanted. Yeah. So he's got to sabotage him in his mind. That's right. So he's going to go over to Kelly's desk and he's going to tell her about the program. Random background catch. If you look past Kelly's bedazzled saber water bottle, you can see a candle that someone has wedged two thumb tacks into. You know those people, those people that have to stick something in a candle. Oh yeah. Yeah. Now that you say it. Yeah. I mean, what is that? I don't know. I've done it. I have an irony alert in the scene. Irony. Okay. Dwight looks at Kelly and says, how many Indian CEOs can you think of? Well, my friends, I think we're looking at one Ms. Mindy Kaling. Yes. She has her own media company
职位或更高的职位，而这正是德怀特一直想要的。所以他必须在脑子里暗中破坏他。没错。因此他要走到凯利的桌子旁，把这个计划告诉她。随意的背景搜寻。如果你仔细看凯利那瓶镶满水钻的萨博水杯后面，你能看到一根蜡烛，上面被人楔了两个图钉。你知道那种人，那种非要在蜡烛里戳点什么的人。哦，是的。是的。经你这么一说。嗯，那是什么？我不知道。我也干过。我在这个场景里发现了一个讽刺彩蛋。讽刺。好的。德怀特看着凯利说：“你能想起多少位印度裔CEO？”嗯，我的朋友们，我想我们正在看着其中一位，那就是明迪·卡灵女士。是的。她有她自己的媒体公司。
Kaling International. I know she's president for sure. She may not be CEO, but I mean please to the queen that is Mindy Kaling. I want you to know there was a deleted scene between Dwight and Gabe later in the episode where Dwight says the same thing to Gabe. How many Indian CEOs can you name? And Gabe lists off a whole bunch. I love that. Back in the conference room, Michael is now going to take over like he does. He's got a whole slideshow ready to go. Yeah. But what Michael is projecting are a series of images that go back and forth between Michael and I guess things intended to turn Donna on. Yeah. Here's Michael's talking head. He says, it's subtle. That's how it works. I show her an image that turns her on and then she looks at me, then back at me,
卡灵国际。我知道她绝对是总裁。她可能不是首席执行官，但我的意思是，向女王明迪·卡灵致敬。我想让你们知道，在这集后面的内容中，德怀特和加布之间有一段被删掉的场景，德怀特对加布说了同样的话。你能说出多少位印度裔首席执行官的名字？加布列举了一大堆。我太喜欢了。回到会议室，迈克尔现在要像往常一样接管了。他准备好了一个幻灯片放映。是的。但迈克尔投影的是一系列在迈克尔和我猜是旨在让唐娜兴奋的事物之间来回切换的图片。是的。这是迈克尔的单人访谈。他说，这很微妙。这就是它的运作方式。我给她看一张让她兴奋的图片，然后她看着我，再看回我，
then back at the image. Soon she doesn't know what is me and what is the image. She just knows that she's turned on. Yes. And then the last slide quickly just says sex. This whole scene made me think of a college advertising class I had where we talked about subliminal messaging. Lady, we had that class in my high school and I wrote my senior paper on the subject. Oh my gosh. Well, I have nothing new to share with you then Jenna, but I will tell you here are a few things I found online and I'm sure you can add to it. According to a website called HubSpot, subliminal messaging and advertising is designed to engage people subconsciously. These ads use various colors, shapes, and words that enable customers to make a small
然后又看回图片。很快她就分不清哪个是我，哪个是图片了。她只知道她兴奋了。是的。然后最后一张幻灯片迅速写着：性。整个场景让我想起了我上过的一个大学广告课，我们在课上讨论了潜意识信息。天哪，女士，我们在高中时就上过那门课，我关于这个主题写了我高年的论文。哦天哪。好吧，那我没有什么新东西可以告诉你了，珍娜，但我会告诉你，我在网上找到了一些东西，我确信你可以补充。根据一个叫HubSpot的网站，潜意识信息和广告旨在潜意识地吸引人们。这些广告使用各种颜色、形状和词语，使客户能够在品牌与预期的含义之间建立小而
but powerful association between a brand and an intended meaning. As I looked up subliminal messaging, Jenna, one guy's name kept coming up. Who? James McDonald Vickery. What did he do? Get ready for this. The whole concept of subliminal messaging was first introduced by him. He was a marketing researcher and in 1957, he claimed that he did an experiment in which moviegoers were repeatedly shown a 1,000, 3,000 second advertisement saying something to the effect of hungry eat popcorn, drink Coca-Cola. Based on these claims, the CIA got involved and did a report called the operational potential of subliminal perception in 1958 that led to subliminal cuts being banned in the US. Wow. The CIA suggested that, quote,
却有力的联想。当我查找潜意识信息时，珍娜，有一个人的名字一直出现。谁？詹姆斯·麦克唐纳·维克里。他做了什么？准备好听这个吧。潜意识信息的整个概念最早就是由他提出的。他是一位营销研究员，在1957年，他声称自己做了一个实验，让电影观众反复观看一个持续1000到3000秒的广告，上面写着类似于“饥饿吃爆米花，喝可口可乐”的内容。基于这些说法，中情局介入了，并在1958年发布了一份名为《潜意识知觉的操作潜力》的报告，这导致潜意识剪辑在美国被禁。哇。中情局暗示，引述：
certain individuals can at certain times and under certain circumstances be influenced to act abnormally without awareness of the influence. Wow. So here's the twist. Vickery provided no explanations for his results or any other details about his study to the public, claiming it was part of a confidential patent. Years later, Stuart Rogers interviewed the theater where Vickery supposedly conducted the experiment, and the theater manager said that no such test ever happened at that theater. What? In a television interview in 1962 for advertising age, Vickery admitted that the original study was a gimmick and that the amount of data was too small to be meaningful. After this interview, Vickery shied away from media attention, but his papers are held by the
“某些人在某些时间和某些情况下，可能会在不知不觉中受到影响，做出不正常的行为。”哇。所以转折来了。维克里没有为他的结果提供任何解释，也没有向公众提供关于他的研究的任何其他细节，声称这是机密专利的一部分。多年后，斯图尔特·罗杰斯采访了维克里据称进行实验的那家剧院，剧院经理表示该剧院从未发生过此类测试。什么？在1962年接受《广告时代》的电视采访时，维克里承认最初的研究是一个噱头，数据量太小，没有意义。在这段采访之后，维克里迴避了媒体的关注，但他的文件被康涅狄格大学的
Thomas J. Dodd Research Center at the University of Connecticut. There have been many commentaries and theories about this since it happened, but I thought that was fascinating. That seems to disprove subliminal advertising works, like it was a hoax. Yes, exactly. Supposedly, Vickery admitted that he never conducted the subliminal experiment, and it was a gimmick to attract customers to his failing marketing business. Oh my gosh. I know, but it started a whole conversation about marketing and advertising and how to attract people to your brand and make associations. This led me to a bunch of websites that talked about subliminal messaging and company logos, and I want to share a few of my favorites. All right. You know the chips tostitos?
托马斯·J·多德研究中心保存着。自从这件事发生以来，有很多评论和理论，但我认为这很迷人。这似乎反驳了潜意识广告的作用，就像它是一个骗局一样。是的，完全如此。据称，维克里承认他从未进行过潜意识实验，这只是为了吸引客户到他失败的营销业务中的一个噱头。哦天哪。我知道，但这引发了一场关于营销和广告的全面对话，讨论如何吸引人们关注你的品牌并建立联想。这引导我访问了一堆讨论潜意识信息和公司标志的网站，我想分享一些我最喜欢的。好的。你知道托斯蒂托斯玉米片吗？
Yep. Okay. So have you ever noticed that the two Ts in the middle of tostitos are two friends sharing chips and salsa? Yes. I thought that was so cute. My son got really obsessed with logos and hidden messages in logos. So about a year ago, I would spend pretty much every Saturday and Sunday looking at logos with him and talking about the hidden messages. This was like a big part of my parenting life for a while. Well, my kids showed me the Baskin Robbins one. Remind me. Okay. So in blue, you know, it says Baskin Robbins. The store is famous for selling 31 flavors of ice cream. And if you look at the non-blue part of the logo that's pink, you can see a three and a one within the B and the R. Oh, good one. I know. Okay. Here's another
是的。好的。那么你有没有注意到托斯蒂托斯中间的那两个T是两个分享玉米片和莎莎酱的朋友？是的。我觉得这太可爱了。我儿子变得非常痴迷于标志和标志中的隐藏信息。所以大约在一年前，我几乎每个星期六和星期天都会和他一起看标志，讨论隐藏的信息。这曾是我一段时间内育儿生活中的一大部分。好吧，我的孩子们给我看了冰雪皇后（Baskin Robbins）的那个。提醒我一下。好的。蓝色的部分，你知道，写着Baskin Robbins。这家店以出售31种口味的冰激凌而闻名。如果你看标志中粉红色的非蓝色部分，你可以在B和R里面看到数字3和1。哦，这个好。我知道。好的，这是另一个
one. The FedEx logo has an arrow between the E and the X. Yes. That's outlined in white. Maybe that's to show the company's speed and delivery. The arrow. Amazon, very recognizable logo. If you notice, there is a yellow arrow that points from the A to the Z. And you know, I'm guessing here the messaging is that they sell everything from A to Z, right? So those were a few of my favorites, but it's very interesting concept or idea about logos and marketing and brands and what we retain from this messaging and if it works with brand association. Well, what do we think? Do we think Donna is picking up on Michael's messages? I think how can you not? I have a little slight show breakdown for you. Oh, I'd love it.
。联邦快递（FedEx）的标志在E和X之间有一个箭头。是的。用白色勾勒出来的。也许那是为了显示公司的速度和送货速度。那个箭头。亚马逊，辨识度很高的标志。如果你注意到，有一个黄色的箭头从A指向Z。你知道，我在这里猜想，传达的信息是他们销售从A到Z的一切，对吧？所以这些是我最喜欢的一些，但这是一个非常有趣的关于标志、营销、品牌以及我们从这些信息中保留了什么的概念或想法，以及它是否对品牌联想有用。好吧，我们怎么想？我们认为唐娜在接受迈克尔的信息吗？我觉得怎么可能不呢？我为你准备了一个幻灯片分解。哦，我很乐意听。
Courtesy of Randy Cordray. At six minutes and 21 seconds, you see a photo of a muscled man in his underwear. This was a licensed stock photo purchased for $350 from Getty Images and the model's name was Raymond Hemmings. At six minutes and 29 seconds, you see a picture of Tom Selick. This was originally scripted to be a rather famous image of a nude Burt Reynolds. On the furry rug. Yes. Yes. I guess that was from Cosmopolitan magazine, but Cosmo's managing editor did not allow us to use it. So we use the picture of Tom Selick instead. That is also a licensed stock photo of Tom Selick from Getty Images. And at six minutes and 35 seconds, the torso of a ripped bodybuilder that Michael is standing in front of
由兰迪·科德雷提供。在6分21秒时，你看到了一张穿着内衣的肌肉男的照片。这是一张以350美元从盖蒂图片社购买的有版权的库存照片，模特的名字叫雷蒙德·海明斯。在6分29秒时，你看到了一张汤姆·塞莱克的照片。这原本剧本设定是一张颇有名的伯特·雷诺兹的裸照。在毛茸茸的地毯上。是的。是的。我猜那是来自《时尚Cosmopolitan》杂志，但Cosmo的执行主编不允许我们使用它。所以我们改用了汤姆·塞莱克的照片。这也是一张来自盖蒂图片社的汤姆·塞莱克有版权的库存照片。在6分35秒时，迈克尔站在一个健美运动员的肌肉发达的躯干前
of. That was also from Getty Images. That is how we built that slide show. This scene is going to end with Michael kind of going in for a kiss. Oh my gosh. Pam and Jim are watching from by the water cooler. Just so cringey. Michael is going to try to recover by calling Jim back in. I think we should take a break. And when we come back, we're going to be in Michael's office with Jim and Pam. And who knew he keeps a tin of shortbread on the ready? I have a fan question all about it. We're in Michael's office. Jim and Pam are trying to reason with Michael. Maybe kissing people at work isn't such a good idea, right? That's right. And mid conversation, Michael goes
。那也是来自盖蒂图片社。我们就是这样制作那个幻灯片的。这个场景将以迈克尔试图去亲吻而结束。哦天哪。潘和吉姆在饮水机旁看着。太尴尬了。迈克尔打算通过把吉姆叫回来来挽回局面。我想我们应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将和吉姆、潘一起在迈克尔的办公室里。谁知道他随时准备着一罐酥饼呢？我有一个关于它的粉丝问题。我们在迈克尔的办公室里。吉姆和潘正试图和迈克尔讲道理。也许在工作时亲吻别人并不是什么好主意，对吧？没错。在谈话进行到一半时，迈克尔说
shortbread. Pam says I'd love one. He has a tartan tin full of shortbread ready to go. Guess what this shortbread cookie produced? What, Sam? It's a fan mail flurry. As you can see, we're keeping Audrey quite busy. I know. That's right. A fan mail flurry from Caitlyn B in Philadelphia and many, many, many, many others. Why does Michael offer Pam a shortbread? It feels super random. Was that an improv moment? Was there supposed to be another scene addressing the shortbread? What's going on? No. This was scripted this way? Yeah. Just this moment? We're never going to hear about shortbread again. There's no deleted scenes about shortbread. I was delighted because I love a shortbread cookie.
酥饼。潘说我很想来一个。他有一个装满酥饼的格子铁罐，随时准备着。你猜这个酥饼产生了什么？什么，萨姆？这是一阵粉丝来信狂潮。如你所见，我们让奥黛丽非常忙碌。我知道。没错。来自费城的凯特琳·B以及许许多多其他人的粉丝来信狂潮。为什么迈克尔要给潘一块酥饼？感觉超级随机。那是即兴发挥吗？本来应该有另一场讨论酥饼的戏吗？怎么回事？没有。剧本就是这么写的？是的。就这一刻？我们再也听不到关于酥饼的事了。没有关于酥饼的被删场景。我很高兴，因为我喜欢酥饼。
I do too. Did you know that shortbread has a ratio of one part white sugar to two parts butter and then there's a little bit of flour, maybe some vanilla, but it does not contain any leavening agent. There is no baking soda, no baking powder. They originated in Scotland. Let me tell you what shortbread cookies are to my life now. They are very important because they do very well gluten-free and I brought some today. Did you really? Yes, I did, ma'am. Oh my gosh. I'm so excited. I'm hungry. As soon as I saw that tin in Michael's office, it made me want to eat a shortbread cookie and I knew that today when we started talking about it, I would want to eat a shortbread cookie. So I brought them. I'm so excited. One of my favorite
我也是。你知道酥饼的比例是一份白糖比两份黄油，然后有一点面粉，可能还有一些香草，但它不含任何膨松剂吗？没有小苏打，没有泡打粉。它们起源于苏格兰。让我告诉你酥饼现在在我的生活中意味着什么。它们非常重要，因为它们非常适合做成无麸质的，我今天带了一些。真的吗？是的，我带了，女士。哦天哪。我太激动了。我饿了。一看到迈克尔办公室里的那个铁罐，就让我想吃酥饼，我知道今天当我们开始谈论它时，我会想吃酥饼。所以我带来了。我太激动了。我最喜欢的
things about the podcast is our show and tell moments, whether it's Scotch and Splenda or Beat Vodka. These are Walker's brand gluten-free pure butter shortbread cookies. You had me at two parts butter. Oh, I know. There you go, lady. Thank y'all. Mm, delicious. So good. Josh does a type of shortbread cookie where he puts a little bit of raspberry jam on it. It's so good. Yeah. It was very popular way to do it. Mm-hmm. Oh, something else I want to bring up about this scene. This is the first time where Pam kind of, what would you call it? Like, she sees Michael's side of things. She says if Donna was really that upset, she would have left by now. I don't know. Yeah. She's then going to have this scene with Jim outside of Michael's
播客的事情之一就是我们的展示和讲述时刻，无论是苏格兰威士忌加代糖还是甜菜伏特加。这些是沃克斯品牌的无麸质纯黄油酥饼。你用“两份黄油”打动了我。哦，我懂。给你，女士。谢谢你们。嗯，真美味。太好了。乔希制作的一种酥饼，上面放了一点覆盆子果酱。太好吃了。是的。这是一种非常流行的做法。嗯哼。哦，我还想提一下关于这个场景的另一件事。这是潘第一次有点，你会怎么称呼它？就像，她看到了迈克尔的那一面。她说如果唐娜真的那么生气，她早就离开了。我不知道。是的。她接下来将在迈克尔办公室
office where she offers to back out and let Jim finish the pitch with Michael. I have two things to point out in this moment. What? Mindy directed this episode and I have to imagine she purposely put Michael behind the blinds, peeping in between Jim and Pam. Every time he creeps in the frame, like if you go to eight minutes, 22 seconds, it cracked me up. And I found a whole bunch of bloopers because clearly it made you and John laugh too. I think we need to hear them. It's whenever Steve comes into frame between the two of you. Okay. Just let him flirt with her. People meet each other all sorts of ways. Who are we to stand the way? Pam, you know he's not going to get anywhere and you know he's going to blow our sail. Who cares? It's not that huge a sail. The Schwab.
外面和吉姆有这样一场戏，她主动提出退出，让吉姆和迈克尔完成推销。我有两点要指出。什么？明迪导演了这一集，我不得不猜想她故意把迈克尔放在百叶窗后面，在吉姆和潘之间窥视。每次他鬼鬼祟祟地进入画幅，比如如果你去看8分22秒，我都笑死了。我找到了厚厚一沓NG镜头，很显然这也让你和约翰笑了。我想我们需要听听看。每当史蒂夫进入你们俩之间的画幅时。好的。就让他调情吧。人们以各种方式相识。我们是谁，凭什么阻拦？潘，你知道他不会有结果的，而且你知道他会搞砸我们的销售。谁在乎？又不是什么大生意。施瓦布。
Pam, you know he's not going to get anywhere and you know he's going to blow our sail. Who cares? It's not that huge a sail. The Schwab guy does. That was right when he came into frame is every time John had to say the Schwab guy and he could not get it out. It was so fun to watch. Well, over in the break room, Dwight is trying to coach Kelly for her interview for the Print in All Colors Initiative and I want you to know. Oh, I know what you're going to say. What am I going to say? Oh, I think I know what you're going to say. What are you going to say? Well, now I'm not sure. Do you think we're going to say the same thing? Do you want to say it at the same time and see if it is? Okay. One, two, three. Scranton Strangler.
潘，你知道他不会有结果的，而且你知道他会搞砸我们的销售。谁在乎？又不是什么大生意。施瓦布那家伙在乎。那就是他进入画幅的那一刻，每次约翰不得不说“施瓦布那家伙”时，他都说不出来。看这个太有趣了。好吧，在休息室里，德怀特正试图指导凯莉参加“彩色打印”倡议的面试，我想让你知道。哦，我知道你要说什么。我要说什么？哦，我想我知道你要说什么。你要说什么？好吧，现在我不确定了。你觉得我们会说同一句话吗？你想同时说出来看看是不是吗？好的。一，二，三。斯克兰顿绞杀魔。
Oh my gosh. Yes. The third mention of the Scranton Strangler this season. Yes. And also we learned that Kelly has some very strong feelings on guys that wear their cell phones outside their pants. She says just put it in your pocket. Yeah, but that's when Dwight mentions the Scranton Strangler. He says wearing his cell phone outside his pants makes it a lot easy for him to say 9-1-1. Hello, Scranton Strangler is inside the house. Inside the house. Yeah. Oh my gosh. Let's do the whole rest of the podcast in use then. Oh my goodness. Yep. I highlighted it. Scranton Strangler mentioned. Back in the bullpen, everybody is watching what's going on in the conference room. Mm-hmm. And they all have a lot of opinions over whether or not Donna is flirting with Michael.
哦天哪。是的。本季第三次提到斯克兰顿绞杀魔。是的。而且我们还了解到，凯莉对把手机挂在裤子外面的男人有着非常强烈的看法。她说直接放进口袋里就好了。是的，但就在那时，德怀特提到了斯克兰顿绞杀魔。他说把手机挂在裤子外面让他更容易说9-1-1。喂，斯克兰顿绞杀魔在屋里。在屋里。是的。哦天哪。那我们用这个词把播客剩下的部分做完吧。哦天哪。是的。我重点标记了。提到了斯克兰顿绞杀魔。回到大办公室，每个人都在看会议室里发生的事情。嗯哼。对于唐娜是否在和迈克尔调情，他们都有很多看法。
This scene was longer and in it we learned what Andy thinks third bass is. Do we get to hear it? Oh, we do. Oh, thank goodness. Baseball. Really? I always thought it was based on orchestra chairs. And now you're telling me there's a third bass in the orchestra. No, that's a bass-heavy orchestra. Oh yeah. And guess what? What? There were candy bag alts for this talking head. Here was one that didn't make it, but that Ed had to deliver as Andy. How do I know a girl's interested? I call her up on stage, get down on one knee, and sing, sign your name by Terrence Trent Darby, then I give her a rose. If she's interested,
这个场景原本更长，在其中我们了解到安迪认为的“三垒”是什么。我们能听到吗？哦，我们可以。哦，谢天谢地。棒球。真的吗？我一直以为它是根据乐队指挥台的椅子来定的。现在你告诉我乐队里还有个三垒？不，那是低音强烈的乐队。哦，是的。你猜怎么着？什么？这段单人访谈有备用糖果包台词。这里有一个没用上，但埃德必须作为安迪说出来的。我怎么知道一个女孩有兴趣？我把她叫上舞台，单膝跪地，唱着特伦斯·特伦特·达比的《签约你的名字》，然后我给她一朵玫瑰。如果她有兴趣，
she'll find me at the CD table. Huh. So how many times did he sing to a gal in a cappella? I don't know. And then go and wait for her at the CD table. Now Donna is going to inquire about a discount, but when she does, she takes her jacket off and I felt like Michael had that same moment that everyone had at Coachella when Harry Styles took his coat off. That was a moment. Who's with me in the sound booth? It was a moment. Cassie, I see you. It was muted, but Cassie giggled immediately. Is the correct response? Well, this causes Michael to make a promise he can't really keep, which is that he's going to give her this discount. But he goes over to check with Oscar who's running the numbers,
她会在CD台找到我。哈。所以他无伴奏清唱给一个姑娘唱了多少次？我不知道。然后去CD台等她。现在唐娜要询问折扣，但当她这么做时，她脱下了夹克，我觉得迈克尔当时的心情就像每个人在哈里·斯泰尔斯脱掉外套时在科切拉音乐节上的心情一样。那真是一个时刻。谁在音响室里跟我一起？那是一个时刻。卡茜，我看到你了。虽然静音了，但卡茜立刻咯咯笑了。这是正确的反应吗？好吧，这导致迈克尔做出一个他无法真正兑现的承诺，那就是他要给她这个折扣。但他过去跟负责算账的奥斯卡确认，
and Oscar says, Michael, we will literally lose money if we sell the printers at that price. I have a question. Okay. I probably should have brought it up earlier. How many printers is Donna buying for her bar that makes this whole day worth it? She manages one sit and dexter. I mean, how much printing are they doing? And then this made me think like in general, how does Saber stay in business? Like paper, you need paper on an ongoing basis. But printers, I mean, how often are you reselling to the same clients? It seems like very difficult. I don't know. The whole arc of Saber and their printers is just like literally falling apart for me all of a sudden. Well, you know, Pam is going to bring that up
奥斯卡说，迈克尔，如果我们以那个价格出售打印机，我们绝对会赔钱。我有一个问题。好的。我可能应该早点提出来的。唐娜为她的酒吧买了几台打印机，以至于这一切都变得值得了？她管理着一家sit and dexter。我是说，他们打印多少东西？这让我想起总体来说，赛博（Saber）公司是怎么维持业务的？比如纸张，你需要源源不断地纸张。但打印机，我是说，你多久向同一客户转售一次？这看起来非常困难。我不知道。赛博及其打印机的整个发展轨迹对我来说突然之间就彻底崩溃了。好吧，你知道，潘会把这个提出来，
in some PAM sass. She's like, you can buy a printer over the phone. You can buy a printer at Best Buy. I mean, I know, you don't have to come in and make such a big show and presentation about it. I could see if we are supplying printers to all of AT&T. Are all of sit and dexters? Maybe it's a chain. Maybe there's going to be 300 printers, but I don't think Donna's in charge of that. No, she manages one. It's very odd to me. Let's go over and see what Kelly and Ryan are doing. They're up to no good. They're bullying someone online. At 10 minutes and 32 seconds, you can see her typing on her computer. That is a fake instant message account created by Henry Zane. I think that's number five. Well, do I just going to learn pretty quickly that
带着一些潘式的讽刺。她说，你可以在电话里买打印机。你可以在百思买买打印机。我是说，我懂，你不需要进来大张旗鼓地做个演示和展示。我可以理解如果我们是在为整个美国电话电报公司（AT&T）供应打印机。或者是所有的sit and dexters？也许是一家连锁店。也许会有300台打印机，但我不认为唐娜负责那个。不，她只管理一家。这对我来说太奇怪了。让我们过去看看凯莉和莱恩在做什么。他们没干好事。他们在网上霸凌别人。在10分32秒时，你可以看到她在电脑上打字。那是亨利·赞恩创建的一个假即时通讯账户。我想那是第五个。好吧，德怀特很快就会了解到，
having Kelly take that position might be worse than Darryl? Because she says she's going to promote Ryan to manager and then they're going to clean house. Yeah. Well, Michael has so many people in the bullpen weighing in on this Donna thing. This starts the whole mint debate. Like if you offer someone a mint and they say, yes, right, they might want to make out if they say, no, they don't want to, he's going to offer Donna a mint, then eat it off her hand. We had a fan question from Stacy C and Charlotte, North Carolina was Michael eating the mint from the palm of Donna's hand improvised because her reaction looks truly surprised. I'll tell you, it was not improvised, but it was also not the original idea in the script. Originally, it's worse. He was going to
让凯莉担任那个职位可能会比达里尔更糟。因为她说她要提拔莱恩为经理，然后他们要大刀阔斧地整顿。是的。好吧，迈克尔在大办公室里有这么多人对这个唐娜的事情评头论足。这就引发了整个薄荷糖辩论。如果有人给你一颗薄荷糖，他们说好，对吧，他们可能想跟你亲热；如果他们说不，他们不想。他要给唐娜一颗薄荷糖，然后从她手上吃掉。我们有一个来自北卡罗来纳州夏洛特的斯黛西·C的粉丝问题：迈克尔从唐娜手掌上吃薄荷糖是即兴发挥吗，因为她的反应看起来真的很惊讶。我告诉你，这不是即兴发挥，但也不是剧本里的最初构想。原本的构想更糟。他打算
put the mint into her mouth very sensually. Oh gosh. On the day, they liked the idea that she would reciprocate the mint, you know, where she eats the mint and then she's like, do you want a mint? That's going to make Michael think like, oh, it's on. And then he would eat the mint off her hand. This is going to bring a meeting in the kitchen. It also brings one of my favorite lines. Which one is it? Why don't you just shut up? Yes. Well, why don't you shut up? Kevin yells that at 12 minutes, three seconds. It's also mine. And I want to point out it sounded exactly like Brian and not like Kevin. You think? Yes. Oh, can we hear it? Well, why don't you just move the M&M? Why don't you shut up? Come on. That sounded just like Brian. I guess. That is Brian.
非常色情地把薄荷糖放进她嘴里。哦天哪。拍摄当天，他们喜欢这样一个主意：她会回请薄荷糖，你知道的，她吃了薄荷糖，然后她说，你要来一颗吗？这会让迈克尔觉得，哦，好戏开场了。然后他会从她手上吃掉薄荷糖。这将在厨房里引发一场会议。这也带来了我最喜欢的一句台词。哪一句？你为什么不直接闭嘴？是的。好吧，你为什么不闭嘴？凯文在12分3秒时大喊。这也是我的。我想指出的是，这听起来完全像布莱恩，而不像凯文。你觉得呢？是的。哦，我们能听听吗？好吧，你为什么不把M&M豆移开？你为什么不闭嘴？得了吧。听起来太像布莱恩了。我猜。那就是布莱恩。
That is, I don't think that's Kevin's voice. Well, during this whole scene, everybody is trying to tell Michael to stop that Donna does not like him back. And then Pam is like, oh, I don't know. Lady, I went to the message boards to see what fans thought of this episode at the time that it aired. And there were three things that got the most mentions. What? One, people loved when Kevin yells at Andy about his M&Ms. Second, people did not think that Pam was acting the same in this episode. Oh, Nick said, am I the only one that thinks Pam was really weird in tonight's episode? Not only the way that she was acting, but how she looked too. Sombreros Our Love said, I completely agree with whoever said Pam was weird. Megan said, I'm worried they're taking
那就是，我不认为那是凯文的声音。好吧，在整个场景中，每个人都试图告诉迈克尔停下来，唐娜并不喜欢他。然后潘说，哦，我不知道。女士，我去了留言板，看看当时播出这一集时粉丝们的看法。有三件事被提及得最多。什么？第一，人们喜欢凯文对安迪大喊大叫关于他的M&M豆。第二，人们认为潘在这集里的表现不太一样。哦，尼克说，难道我是唯一一个觉得潘在今晚的这一集里真的很怪异的人吗？不仅是她的行为方式，还有她的外表也是。Sombreros Our Love说，我完全同意任何说潘很怪异的人。梅根说，我很担心他们把
Jim and Pam in a weird direction, mainly Pam. Wow. But then Sarah defended Pam by saying, how is she acting weird? She was trying to help Michael with his love life. And Megan agreed, saying Pam always has a soft spot for Michael's love life and is advising him on what to do. What do you think? Did you think it was weird? I guess the only part that was weird for me is how long she stuck in there with him. Pam? Yeah. Like in the beginning of the episode, all the information is new. So I could see her being like, well, you know, guys, we don't know. Maybe she likes him. I mean, she's here, right? But I felt like as the day went, how I normally associate Pam as like the voice of reason would
吉姆和潘带向了一个怪异的方向，主要是潘。哇。但接着萨拉为潘辩护说，她怎么奇怪了？她一直在试图帮迈克尔的爱情生活。梅根表示同意，说潘对迈克尔的爱情生活总是心软，一直在给他提供该怎么做的建议。你怎么看？你觉得这很奇怪吗？我想对我来说唯一奇怪的部分是她陪着他陷得有多深。潘？是的。就像在这一集刚开始时，所有的信息都是新的。所以我可以理解她会觉得，嗯，你知道，各位，我们不知道。也许她喜欢他。我是说，她人在这儿，对吧？但我觉得随着时间的推移，我通常将潘联系在一起的形象，作为理智的声音，
have been like, no, Michael, I take it all back. He's just pumped the brakes. As Jenna, when I was watching this episode, as soon as I kind of saw her like manipulating him, like taking off her extra jacket, I started to think, oh, that's what's happening. She wants a discount on her printer. Right. Yeah. And she's just flirting for that reason. But I would like to say Pam didn't see that. I as a viewer saw that, but Pam doesn't know that, right? So she's still thinking, maybe she's there for Michael, not for a printer. Anyway, finally, a lot of people on the message boards mentioned that they didn't get any new information on the Andy Aaron storyline. And they were very disappointed, you know, because they had
应该会说，不，迈克尔，我收回刚才的话。踩住刹车吧。作为珍娜，当我观看这一集时，一旦我看到她那种操控他的行为，比如脱掉多余的夹克，我开始心想，哦，原来是这么回事。她想在打印机上打折。对。是的。她调情纯粹是为了那个原因。但我得说，潘当时没看出这一点。我作为观众看出来了，但潘并不知道，对吧？所以她依然觉得，也许她是为迈克尔来的，而不是为了打印机。无论如何，最后，留言板上的很多人提到他们没有从安迪和艾琳的故事线中得到任何新信息。他们感到非常失望，你知道的，因为他们上周刚刚经历了一场非常大的分手。
a very big breakup last week. And they would have liked to have seen some mention of it. You know, I think they're not going to get much next week either. Well, you know, there actually is a scene between Andy and Aaron that would have been in next week's episode. It's in the deleted scenes. I'll share it next week. Oh, all right. Well, Dwight is still freaking out about the idea of Kelly and Ryan running things. He burst into Gabe's office. And this is when he finds out that Daryl has withdrawn his application. He says he has a scheduling conflict with softball. Yeah, Daryl says he has his whole life to be a minority executive, but he only has about one year left in his knees. Kelly is now the only applicant. Yeah. And she is going to walk
他们希望看到对此有所提及。你知道，我觉得他们下周也不会得到太多。好吧，你知道，安迪和艾琳之间其实有一场戏本应出现在下周的那一集中。它在被删减片段里。我下周会分享它。哦，好吧。好吧，德怀特仍然对凯莉和莱恩掌权的想法感到抓狂。他冲进加布的办公室。就在这时，他发现达里尔撤回了申请。他说他有垒球比赛的时间冲突。是的，达里尔说他有一辈子的时间去当少数族裔高管，但他膝盖的黄金时期只剩大约一年了。凯莉现在是唯一的申请人了。是的，她要走进
into her interview with Gabe. She's wearing a beautiful sorry. Mm hmm. Gabe asks her about the bindi that is on her forehead. She says she's offended by the question. She won't answer. But Kelly will tell Gabe about all of her hobbies. And in the middle of this, Dwight is going to return with a new applicant and it is Hide. He tells Hide to share his life story and Hide begins his same monologue that he gave in happy hour. It delighted me. I asked Hide what it was like doing that amazing talking head and happy hour. And here's what he said. I actually did not get a lot of time to think about the big speech for the episode since I got five different variations of my speech at around 10pm the day before. Oh my gosh. Yeah. I desperately tried to memorize
加布的办公室去面试。她穿着一件美丽的纱丽。嗯哼。加布问起她额头上的蒂卡（Bindi）。她说这个问题冒犯了她。她不会回答。但凯莉会向加布讲述她的所有爱好。而在这一切进行到一半时，德怀特带着一个新的申请人回来了，那就是Hide。他让Hide分享他人生的故事，Hide开始了他在欢乐时光（Happy Hour）里发表过的同一段独白。这让我太开心了。我问Hide在欢乐时光里做那段精彩的单人独白是什么感觉，他是这么说的。我其实没有太多时间去思考那一集的大段台词，因为在前一天晚上10点左右，我拿到了我台词的五种不同变体。哦天哪。是的，我拼命地试图记住
all five variations. When I went to the rehearsal, I completely forgot everything. He went on to say that he decided he was going to work hard to memorize all the different variations so that he'd be ready to go on the shoot day. When the day came to actually film the scene, he said he was able to say his lines perfectly. And he said, I remember I was so happy I was able to do it on the first take or two. I love it. He nailed it. Totally nailed it. I mean, it's so good. I also asked Hide if he still gets recognized for his role in the office. He said, yes. And he has a very sweet story to share. He said, after doing the big heart surgeon speech, I started to get some people in the street randomly asking me if I was the guy from the office.
所有五种变体。当我走进排练场时，我把一切都忘得精光。他接着说，他决定要努力记住所有不同的变体，以便在拍摄当天准备就绪。当真正拍摄这一场景的日子到来时，他说他能够完美地说出他的台词。他说，我记得我当时太高兴了，因为我只用了一两次就完成了。我太喜欢了。他完美驾驭了。完全完美驾驭了。我是说，太棒了。我还问Hide，他是否仍然因为他在《办公室》中的角色而被认出来。他说，是的。他有一个非常甜蜜的故事要分享。他说，在做完那个伟大的心脏外科医生演讲后，我开始在街上随机遇到一些人问我是不是《办公室》里的那个家伙。
I was very surprised because I had no idea the show was so popular at the time. I remember I had to quickly come up with a fancy autograph because I never thought I would have people asking me for autographs. But his favorite time getting recognized, he said, was by a fan. It was a little kid who did the signature the best. Double thumbs up to him without saying a word while I was in the supermarket. Oh, I love that. The last question I asked Hide was if he took if he took anything from set when the show was over. He said he wasn't there on the last episode, but he did receive an official jacket after the show wrapped. He said it was a really nice jacket and one day a fan wanted it so badly that I autographed it and I gave it away. He's the
我非常惊讶，因为我当时根本不知道这部剧这么受欢迎。我记得我不得不迅速想出一个花哨的签名，因为我从来没想过会有人找我要签名。但他最喜欢的被认出来的时刻，他说，是一个粉丝。那是一个小孩子，在我去超市时，一言不发地向他竖起了双大拇指。哦，我太喜欢这个了。我问Hide的最后一个问题是，当节目结束时，他是否从片场拿走了什么东西。他说他最后一集不在现场，但在节目杀青后他确实收到了一件官方夹克。他说那是一件非常漂亮的夹克，有一天一个粉丝太想要它了，于是我就在上面签名并把它送人了。他是
sweetest person. So lovely. He said that he was hoping to get the warehouse worker uniform that he wore during the show. But he was informed by a fan that his uniform was sold at the end of the NBC auction. So he tried his best to bid on it so he could get it. But unfortunately, he was outbid in the end. But he goes on to say, I am happy someone liked my role so much that they fought really hard for the uniform and it's in the hands of a happy fan. Well, Hide, I think that is such a sweet point of view on a story that just kind of made me mad. I know. I want Hide to have his uniform. Isn't he on Cameo, Ange? Yes, he is. Yeah, Cameo is the place where you can find different celebrities and public figures and you pay a small fee and
最温柔的人。太可爱了。他说他曾希望得到他在剧中穿过的仓库工人的制服。但他被一个粉丝告知，他的制服在NBC拍卖会结束时被卖掉了。所以他尽最大努力去竞拍它，以便能把它弄到手。但不幸的是，最后他竞标失败了。但他接着说，我很高兴有人那么喜欢我的角色，以至于他们为了这件制服拼尽全力，而且它现在在一个快乐的粉丝手中。好吧，Hide，我觉得对于一个本来让我有点生气的经历，你有着如此甜美的视角。我知道。我希望Hide能拥有他的制服。他在Cameo上，安吉？是的，他在。是的，Cameo是一个你可以找到各种名人和公众人物的地方，你支付一小笔费用，
they'll make a personal video for you. Yes, Hide shared with us that he just started doing Cameo for fun. But if anyone wants a personal video message of him as his character, you can go to Cameo and find him. He is also on Instagram at Hide Toshimura, H-I-D-E-T-O-S-H-I-I-M-U-R-A. And you can follow him there. He says he posts pretty often. Thank you so much, Hide. Thank you. I'm so glad we got in touch with him. Good job, Ange. Aw. Well, I guess Donna has finally purchased her printer, printers. How many did she need? We don't know, but the deal is done. Michael is going to walk her out very awkwardly. There's an awkward hug. He follows her all the way to nearly the elevators. Yes.
他们就会为你制作一个个人视频。是的，Hide跟我们分享说，他刚刚开始在Cameo上好玩。但如果任何人想要一个他作为角色的个人视频信息，你可以去Cameo找到他。他还在Instagram上，账号是Hide Toshimura，H-I-D-E-T-O-S-H-I-I-M-U-R-A。你可以在那里关注他。他说他发帖挺频繁的。非常感谢你，Hide。谢谢。我很高兴我们联系上了他。干得好，安吉。啊。好吧，我想唐娜终于买下了她的打印机，打印机。她到底需要多少台？我们不知道，但交易已经完成了。迈克尔将非常尴尬地把她送出去。有一个尴尬的拥抱。他一直跟着她走到几乎电梯口。是的。
By the way, at 15 minutes and 11 seconds, remember last time I was talking about the picture? That big print? Yes. I got a closer look at it. It's a Valley of Trees with a waterfall. So, I got closure on that. Okay, I'm really glad. I appreciated it. Michael's pretty glum now. Donna's gone. He says he can't trust his own feelings anymore. And everyone's weighing in on it. And he comes in with, you know, when I tore my scrote. Yeah. I was seeing a hot urologist, and I thought she was into me. It gets confusing down there. I have a fan catch from Sergio P. in Mexico. I wonder if Sergio and I have the same catch. Does it happen at 17 minutes and 18 seconds? And does it involve Pam's desk? No. What is it? All right. Sergio said,
顺便说一句，在15分11秒时，还记得上次我在谈论那幅画吗？那幅巨大的印刷品？是的。我凑近看了一下。那是一幅带有瀑布的树木山谷。所以，我对那件事释怀了。好的，我真的很高兴。我很感激。迈克尔现在相当沮丧。唐娜走了。他说他再也不相信自己的感觉了。每个人都在对此评头论足。然后他冒出一句，你知道当我撕裂了我的阴囊时。是的。我当时在看一个性感的女泌尿科医生，我以为她对我有意思。那下面真的很容易让人搞混。我有一个来自墨西哥的塞尔吉奥·P的粉丝发现。我在想塞尔吉奥和我发现的是不是同一个。它发生在17分18秒吗？它和潘的办公桌有关吗？没有。是什么？好吧，塞尔吉奥说，
if you look under Pam's desk, there's a piece of masking tape on it that says Pam. He said, is that because you would move the set around and take out the desks? What a great catch. Yes. That's exactly why. Sergio, I live for that catch. What's yours? Mine is at 18 minutes, seven seconds. What's up with the stains on the wall? Stains on the wall? Oh, there are two stains on the wall by Michael's left shoulder as he is sitting in the chair. Two stains. Yeah. No, it's gross. What do they look like? Do they look like hands? Do they look like what? I don't know if this is because I was eating barbecue chips at the time. They look like when my kids wipe barbecue chip hands on things. Oh, gosh. Yeah. Gross. I know.
如果你看潘的办公桌下面，上面有一条写着“潘”的遮蔽胶带。他说，那是因为你们会把片场移来移去然后把桌子搬走吗？多么棒的发现。是的。完全就是因为这个。塞尔吉奥，我就是为了这样的发现而活的。你的是什么？我的是在18分7秒。墙上的那些污渍是怎么回事？墙上的污渍？哦，迈克尔坐在椅子上时，他左肩膀旁的墙上有两个污渍。两个污渍。是的。不，太恶心了。它们看起来像什么？它们看起来像手吗？它们看起来像什么？我不知道这是否是因为我当时在吃烧烤味薯片。它们看起来就像我的孩子们把沾满烧烤味薯片的手抹在东西上一样。哦，天哪。是的。真恶心。我知道。
I know. It's all I could look at. Well, two more things are going to happen in this scene. Gabe announces that Kelly is the newest member of the minority executive program, and Erin finds Donna's hair clip that she left behind. Mm-hmm. Michael thinks it's a sign. She left it on purpose. Everyone is like, no, no, no, Michael. No. But he's going to run out to give it to her. He is. And guess what? She says, Michael, you were right. And she pulls him in for a big kiss. And all I could think of was, Donna, this is a documentary. It's going to air at some point. We'll get to that next week. We sure will. But this was a bit of a spy shot,
我知道。我只能看到那个。好吧，这个场景里还有两件事要发生。加布宣布凯莉是少数族裔高管项目的最新成员，而艾琳找到了唐娜落下的发夹。嗯哼。迈克尔认为这是一个征兆。她是故意留下的。每个人都说，不，不，不，迈克尔。不。但他还是要跑出去把它还给她。是的。你猜怎么着？她说，迈克尔，你是对的。然后她把他拉过去来了个大大的吻。我当时脑子里唯一想到的就是，唐娜，这是一部纪录片。它总有一天会播出的。我们下周再聊这个。我们一定会的。但这是一个有点像偷拍的镜头，
so I believe it that she didn't see the camera. I believe it. It was from the office window pointing down into the parking lot. Well, next week, we're going to find out why she had to be so coy, like around others, around the cameras, how she could only admit her true feelings for Michael when she thought they were alone. Mm-hmm. I mean, it's literally the plot of next week's episode. Michael's going to come back to the office where Kelly is gloating. She tells Erin, you know what? She gets a stipend to buy all new clothes, and Erin can have, like, any of her old stuff. That she can buy them. Yeah. She's not giving them to Erin. Erin can buy them. And she means any of the clothes she was going to give to Goodwill anyway.
所以我相信她没有看到摄像机。我相信。那是从办公室窗户向下对准停车场拍的。好吧，下周，我们将找出为什么她必须表现得如此羞涩，比如在其他人面前、在摄像机前，她怎么能在以为四下无人的时候才承认她对迈克尔的真实情感。嗯哼。我的意思是，这简直就是下周那一集的剧情。迈克尔要回到办公室，凯莉正在那里幸灾乐祸。她告诉艾琳，你知道吗？她有一笔津贴可以买全新衣服，而艾琳可以拿走她任何旧东西。是她可以买。是的。她不是送给艾琳。艾琳可以买。她的意思是她本来就要捐给慈善商店的那些衣服。
Right. But Erin can pay her for them. Mm-hmm. Michael can't help himself. He's going to tell everyone what just happened, but no one believes him. Nope. And he says it doesn't matter if they believe him or not, because he knows it happened. Also, I did it. And that is the end of the episode. Thank you guys so much for rewatching with us. Thank you Tahide and to Randy. And thanks to Audrey for some fun stings. Yeah. We will be back next week with the cover-up. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher.
对吧。但艾琳得为它们付钱。嗯哼。迈克尔情不自禁。他要告诉每个人刚刚发生了什么，但没有人相信他。没错。他说别人信不信并不重要，因为他知道事情发生了。另外，我确实做了。这就是这一集的结尾。非常感谢大家和我们一起重温。感谢Hide和兰迪。感谢奥黛丽带来一些有趣的音效转场。是的。我们下周带着《掩盖》归来。到时候见。感谢收听“办公室女士们”。“办公室女士们”由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。
Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的制片人是卡茜·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。有关“办公室女士们”的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。在Stitcher Premium上免费试用一个月，请使用代码 OFFICE。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。